18 years ago one of the greatest games
ever made was released on the Nintendo
GameCube in the time since Resident Evil
4 has made its way onto other platforms
including virtual reality and now it's
coming to the current generation of
consoles with a new yet familiar coat of
paint here's everything you need to know
about the remake of Resident Evil 4.
original re4 then you should have a
pretty good idea of what to expect from
the Remake story in Resident Evil 4 you
play as Leon S Kennedy and you're on a
mission to rescue the American
president's daughter Ashley Graham from
a mysterious cult called Los illuminatos
Ashley's whereabouts bring you to the
rule outskirts of Spain where villagers
have become infected by Las plagas a
parasite capable of Mind Control this is
far from an ideal welcome party but
fortunately and also unfortunately for
Mr Kennedy he is somewhat familiar with
the spread of deadly viruses this once
upon a time rookie Cobb dealt with the
t-virus during the events of Resident
Evil 2. another game that got the very
popular remake treatment back in 2019
however you won't be completely lost if
you haven't played re2 as the opening of
part 4 sees Leon dumping a bit of
exposition on you in the remakes version
of this brief scene Capcom takes the
opportunity to flesh out Leon's
character early on in our our Hands-On
preview with the game Kurt indovina
wrote quote this intro creates weight
and empathy for him that I hope is
explored more in the game and thankfully
that seems to be the case according to
Resident Evil 4 remake producer yoshiaki
hirobayashi Leon is struck with regrets
from the Raccoon City incident and while
preserving the original game's story is
the top priority he indicated that
Leon's experience from that fateful
night will remain a Common Thread
throughout now without getting into
spoiler territory for those who haven't
played the original just know that you
can look forward to some familiar faces
like Ada Wong bitores Mendez Ramon
Salazar and more
yeah
Resident Evil 4 is a third person
survival horror game and even though the
Remake is aiming to stay true to the
gameplay of the original Capcom has
modernized a few things in order to
bring the game up to today's standards
for example the Remake has incorporated
trends like stealth and there is more of
an emphasis on Survival this time around
this is counterbalanced by being able to
sneak around as well as craft ammunition
and health items a la The Last of Us
unlike the rather linear approach of the
original the Remake is more expansive
giving the player more space to wander
and explore areas off the beaten path
this Freedom extends Beyond land as the
new re4 also gives you the opportunity
to explore my motorboat outside of the
Del Lago boss fight freely controlling
the motorboat means you can Traverse the
watery depths of caverns and explore
other areas entirely many of these areas
seem to be gated off but can be accessed
by solving small puzzles similar to the
insignia puzzles seen only once outside
of The Village Church in the original
but exploration isn't everything and
re4's remake contains some changes to
combat as well for starters executions
have been added to the mix and all you
fans of soulsborne's might be happy to
hear that your parrying skills will come
into play during your time with re4
remake based on the gameplay we saw just
about anything can be buried with Leon's
knife chainsaws Airborne torches
speeding arrows or even the nasty
tentacle claws of head erupted parasites
however this Hefty upgrade and
functionality does not come without some
compromises unlike the original the
knife now has a durability bar akin to
Resident Evil 2 remakes take on the
knife so while the extra versatility
adds more variety to Resident Evil 4's
combat formula it's not without some
Resource Management considerations also
new to Resident Evil 4 remake is the
addition of storage a staple in many
other installations of the franchise but
omitted from the original re4 whenever
Leon visits a typewriter the player can
now store items there this is
significant considering that if you've
ran out of room in your case in the
original you'd have to sell or abandon
those items which sometimes meant
parting ways with weapons too for even
more about the changes coming to the
Remake check out our video Resident Evil
4 remake 11 things we learned from the
new gameplay
Resident Evil 4 remake is being
developed and published by Capcom the
project reportedly began development in
2018 with M2 a Capcom backed Studio
started by the former CEO of Platinum
Games the project was then shifted over
to division one in early 2021 where many
of the developers that worked on the re2
Remake returned for the remake of re4
among that returning crew is yashahiro
ampo who led the charge as director in
2019 and takes the driver's seat again
for this project yoshiaki hirobayashi is
riding beside him and has taken the
honor of being the game's producer
thank you
Resident Evil 4 is coming to Playstation
4 PlayStation 5 Xbox One Xbox series X
and S and PC via Steam on March 24th
2023. the game will have three different
versions to choose from standard Deluxe
and collector's edition the standard
edition will cost 60 USD and only
includes the base game however
pre-ordering this edition of The Game on
any platform will give you access to the
gold attache case and the handgun ammo
charm the deluxe edition of the game
costs 70 usd and comes with the extra
DLC pack this pack includes casual and
romantic costumes for Leon and Ashley a
hero and a villain costume and filter
for Leon The Sentinel 9 and skull Shaker
Deluxe weapons the expansion treasure
map sporty glasses for Leon and the
original version soundtrack Swap and
finally the collector's edition this
version retails for 250 USD and comes
with a product code for the extra DLC
attack as well as a handful of physical
goodies these include a steelbook case
the full digital soundtrack an art book
a special map a collector's box and a
figure of Mr Kennedy players who
pre-ordered the deluxe and collectors
editions get the classic attache case
and the green herb charm as well as the
gold case and ammo charm I mentioned
earlier players who pre-ordered the
digital standard and Deluxe editions on
PlayStation 4 and 5 will receive a mini
soundtrack for the game in addition to
the cases and charms associated with
each version also exclusive to
PlayStation 5 is a virtual reality
version of the game for psvr 2. there
currently isn't a release date or window
for this version but when development is
done it will come to Sony's latest
headset for free to owners of the base
game on PlayStation 5. if you're on the
fence about buying Resident Evil 4
remake you should check out the game's
free demo revealed on March 9th during
the Capcom Spotlight the Resident Evil 4
chainsaw demo puts you in Leon's shoes
for the opening moments of the game and
features no time element like previous
re demos have what's more this demo is
not exclusive and can be downloaded from
any of the platforms the full game is
available on and there you have it
everything you need to know about the
remake of Resident Evil 4. if you're a
fan of the original hit the comment
section and tell us some of your
favorite memories with the game for more
information on Resident Evil 4 including
guides and a review make sure you're
subscribed to Gamespot on YouTube and
keep an eye on gamespot.com for more
updates